The United States and North Korea
two countries that can’t seem to find a
path to peace
but solving the conflict might come down to the meaning of a word
President Trump: denuclearization is a
very important, it’s a very important word,
become a very well-used word and a lot of
people don’t know what it means
but to me it’s pretty obvious, we have to get rid of the nukes.
For many U.S. administrations
“denuclearization” has meant
North Korea will:
* destroy all of its nuclear weapons
* destroy its ballistic missiles
* and abandon its nuclear program
but North Korean leaders don’t see it that
way
For them, denuclearization is a process that
would result in
total disarmament of the Korean Peninsula
That means the United States would have to:
* withdraw all of its troops from South Korea
* and end its treaty alliance with South Korea
before North Korea would give up its nuclear program
Some experts even think North Korea wants
the U.S. to:
* withdraw all of its troops from Japan
* end its treaty alliance with Japan
* and destroy the entire U.S. nuclear arsenal
conditions Washington is unlikely to accept
With this vast difference in the meaning of
denuclearization
it’s easy to understand why there has been
no resolution
and unless the two sides can agree on what
denuclearization means
it will be hard to overcome hostility on the
Korean Peninsula